- HELLO.
TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE CANING OF CHARLES SUMNER.
[chuckles]
- IN THE MIDDLE OF THE 1800s,
KANSAS IS UP FOR WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S GOING TO BE A SLAVE STATE
OR A FREE STATE.
CHARLES SUMNER IS A SENATOR,
AN ANTI-SLAVERY RADICAL.
AND CHARLES SUMNER GIVES
A SPEECH ENTITLED
"THE CRIME AGAINST KANSAS."
HE BASICALLY SAYS,
KANSAS IS BEING RAPED BY
THE PERPETUATORS OF SLAVERY
WHO WANT IT TO BE A SLAVE STATE.
THEN HE STARTS MAKING
PERSONAL ATTACKS.
HE SAYS, OH, ANDREW BUTLER,
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA,
WHO NORMALLY SITS NEXT TO ME,
BUT UH-OH, YOU HAD A STROKE.
YOU ARE NOT HERE.
GUESS WHAT?
YOU ARE A [bleep] PIMP
FOR THE PROSTITUTE OF SLAVERY.
OH, YOU KNOW WHO'S
IN THE CHAMBER THAT DAY?
PRESTON BROOKS, REPRESENTATIVE,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
ANDREW BUTLER'S SECOND COUSIN.
HE'S LIKE, THIS DUDE IS [bleep]
SLANDERING MY STATE.
HE'S SLANDERING MY FAMILY.
AND HE SAYS, UHHH.
[blows raspberry]
AND THE SOUTHERN
CODE OF HONOR.
I CAN'T LET THIS [bleep] JUST
[bleep] TRANSPIRE.
WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
I CAN'T CHALLENGE HIM TO A DUEL
BECAUSE ONLY GENTLEMEN DUEL,
AND CHARLES SUMNER'S
IS NO GENTLEMAN.
OH, [bleep].
I WAS JUST GIVEN
A BRAND-NEW
11 1/2 OUNCE
GUTTA-PERCHA CANE
WITH A GOLD HEAD.
I'LL BEAT HIM WITH THAT.
MAY 22, 1856.
HE WALKS DOWN
THE AISLE OF THE SENATE.
HE'S FIVE [bleep] FEET
FROM CHARLES SUMNER
AND HE LOOKS UP
AND HE REALIZES
THERE'S A LADY
IN THE CHAMBER.
HE'S LIKE, OH, [bleep].
I CAN'T BEAT CHARLES SUMNER
IN FRONT OF A LADY
AND HE SITS ACROSS THE AISLE.
HE LEAVES.
HE'S LIKE,
NO, I'M NOT DOING THIS THING.
AND THEN EVERYONE'S JUST LIKE,
YOU GOT TO DO THE THING,
AND HE WALKS BACK IN.
[bleep] CHARLES SUMNER,
HE'S NEAR-SIGHTED.
HE'S LIKE, OH,
THAT'S ALL BLURRY AND [bleep].
[bleep] PRESTON BROOKS IS LIKE,
I READ YOUR SPEECH TWICE,
AND GUESS WHAT?
IT'S A [bleep] LIBEL
AGAINST SOUTH CAROLINA
AND IT'S A LIBEL
AGAINST ANDREW BUTLER.
AND GUESS WHAT?
HE'S A [bleep] COUSIN OF MINE.
AND WHACK!
BEATS HIM SO HARD
ON THE [bleep] TOP OF THE HEAD
THAT HE GOES BLIND.
LAURENCE KEITT COMES IN.
LET THEM BE, HE SAID.